mené par la russie en ukraine en est à
son deuxième jour une autre guerre a
lieu sur les réseaux sociaux celle de la
désinformation c'est aussi une arme de
guerre des informations qui rime avec
décontextualisation et beaucoup de
photos et de vidéos qui circulent
actuellement sur internet ont en effet
sorti sur l'heure de leur contexte est
un grand classique plusieurs exemples ce
soir sélectionnés et décortiqué par
injection par la rédaction des
observateurs de france 24 celui que vous
voyez est derrière moi tout d'abord ce
sont ces avions de combat qui survole un
immeuble une ville publié ce tweet hier
et qui a été vue plus de 200 mille fois
la légende nous dit quoi poutine en voit
en train d'envoyer donc des avions de
combat russes sauf que ça n'a rien de
vrai on retrouve la version originale en
tout cas l'origine de la photo grâce à
une recherche d'image inversée via ayant
d'aix le moteur de recherche russe il
s'agit en fait d'une vidéo de répétition
pour un défilé militaire russe près de
moscou et regardait la date publié donc
via ce compte youtube c'est le 4 mai
2020 on a aussi une autre une autre
séquence qui est l'une des séquences
présente dans le tweet original on reste
dans les airs avec le deuxième exemple
une vidéo que vous avez peut-être vu
circuler regardez elle est reprise ici
sur twitter elle cumule vous regardez
plus près de 190 milles vue et
cette vidéo en fait elle a été postée
hier depuis ce compte twitter ce conte
tik tok pardon romane adler 1 2 300
contexte mais attribuée aux dernières
actualités en ukraine certains évoquant
même ce parachutiste horus filmant son
arrivée sur le front et craignent un et
ça a cumulé près de 30 millions de vues
sur ce compte top avant qu'elle
disparaisse parce qu'elle n'existe plus
et bien là encore c'est faux ça n'a
absolument rien à voir avec la réalité
et on trouve l'origine assez simplement
finalement il suffit de a tapé ce mot
romana de l'air 1 2 3 sur google et vous
retombez sur un compte instagram avec la
vidéo en question et vous voyez très
rapidement que la vidéo a été publiée le
25 août 2015 donc rien à voir avec
l'ukraine actuellement on n'en sait pas
davantage sur le compte le contexte
parce qu'on n'a pas fait de recherches
complémentaires la date suffit à vous
dire que ça a été des contextualiser et
une autre vidéo aussi beaucoup circulé
la firme montré des tanks russes
détruits par des drones ukrainien dont
il y aurait là découvrez ensemble
sérigne cette vidéo regardez la légende
de cette vidéo elle affirme que d un
drone ukrainien donc détruit des chars
russes cette vidéo on la retrouvait
retrouver parce qu'elle a été supprimé
depuis elle a encore sur le média en
ligne biélorusse next à la biélorussie
on le sait allier de vladimir poutine
regarder ce tweet alors d'extras et la
chaîne en question c'est l'une des
principales sources de l'opposition
biélorusse elle ne mentionne pas ici
contrairement à la vidéo qu'on a vu la
nationalité des drones mais l'idée de
ces deux publications c'est de dire
finalement que l'ukraine se défend face
à l'attaquant à l'opposant russe sauf
que là encore lorsque vous procédez une
recherche d'image inversée bien ça n'a
absolument rien à voir avec le cren non
on retrouve cette même vidéo le 3 mars
2020 et il s'agit d'une frappe de drone
en syrie en l'occurrence au sud d'idlib
les exemples de décontextualisation sont
légion preuve en est cette photo oui
regardez cette photo publiée sur ce
compte twitter elle affirmait hier qu'il
s'agissait du drapeau russe alors ça
c'est vrai il n'y a pas de doute
là-dessus dressé sur allah ri de quiet
de kharkiv pardon dans l'est de
l'ukraine avec même vous le voyez le
hashtag troisième guerre mondiale là
encore c'est la recherche d'image
inversée qui va nous aider via le moteur
russe yandex ça nous ramène à l'original
en l'occurrence cette photo reuters
photos que l'on retrouve par exemple
dans cet article du quotidien économique
russe kommersant
et regardez bien la date c'est très
important le 2 mars 2014 on est en
pleine guerre de crimée alors scénario
qui c'est vrai présente des similitudes
avec la situation actuelle mais on
s'arrête là pour la comparaison et la
légende de nous dire que cette cet
article en l'occurrence cette photo il
s'agit de militants pro russe qui
installe effectivement le drapeau russe
à l'entrée du conseil régional de cartes
if kharkiv car ça c'est vrai on est bien
à kharkiv dans l'est de l'ukraine et
parmi ce flot d'un phoque s'il est aussi
des vidéos authentique oui notamment
celle ci est assez impressionnante assez
violente regardez ça va très vite ce
char qui écrase littéralement un
véhicule il y à d'autres prises de vues
de 7
incidents de cet accident voilà par
exemple en face d'un résident d'un
voisin donc prise d'une fenêtre il ya
aussi cet autre autres prisonniers vu
cet autre angle qui nous montre bien la
violence du choc alors ce que l'on sait
justement grâce aux différents angles et
à la géolocalisation c'est que cet
accident il a bien eu lieu ce vendredi
matin en l'occurrence ici à obolon dans
le nord-ouest de kiev la capitale et
plus précisément ici au point rouge à
cette intersection ce qu'on ne sait pas
pour autant pour l'instant en tout cas
avec certitude c'est puisque les
investisse il évince destination pardon
sont encore en course et si ce char et
russes ou ukrainiens et aussi quel est
le contexte pourquoi at il pu at il dû
dévier sa route à s'est subitement comme
on le voit sur la vidéo est bien là
c'est encore en cours de recherche on
n'a pas de réponse définitive mais ce
qu'on sait c'est que la vidéo est bien
authentique ce que je vous disais c'est
que ça a bien eu lieu ce matin à cet
endroit là et puis figurez-vous tout de
même que la bonne nouvelle entre contes
ou entre guillemets de cet accident
c'est que le véhicule lui n'a pas
survécu au temps vous dire mais la
personne l'automobiliste qui le
conduisait a survécu et c'est incroyable
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle avant
d'avoir la chance un miracle c'est ce
qu'on n'a pu à découvrir car là aussi
c'est une vidéo authentique vous voyez
que les passants sont venus le secourir
sept cette invasion russe a fait naître
d un fox mais aussi des théories du
complot oui on va en aborder deux
d'entre elles a rapidement la première
c'est celle qui a été réparée par
exemple par l'un des spécialistes du
détricotage des théories du complot le
daemon coeur des étoiles
vladimir poutine le président russe
ciblerait desbiaux laboratoires
américains secrets en ukraine et c'est
pour ça qu'il ciblerait non pas l'est de
l'ukraine uniquement mais bien tout le
pays vous voyez au dessin venitia kiev
la capitale évidemment là encore la
pandémie de kobe de 19 elle n'est pas
lien puis n'est pas loin pardon la
deuxième c'est que cette guerre en
ukraine serait un plan celui d' emmanuel
macron pour conserver le pouvoir on est
à un mois et demi un peu plus d'un mois
et demi de la présidentielle on sait que
emmanuel macron à s'est posé en
médiateur dans cette crise à la fois
entre la russie et l'ukraine cette thèse
d'un plan emmanuel macron elle est
soutenue notamment par richard boutry
anciens amis animateurs vidéo du site de
france soir c'était la chronique info ou
intox avec anthony servage et merci
anthony